nearly half of the eu's land surface is
covered with forests
wooded areas are europe's lungs they
purify the air we breathe
and protect our biodiversity meps are
calling for an eu
forest strategy to help reach the green
deal goal of reducing 60 percent of co2
emissions by 2030
compared to 1990 levels the enhancement
of biodiversity the fight against
climate change and
the transitions to circular bioeconomy
and to a fossil free society
will never be possible without
multifunctional
healthy and sustainably managed forests
europe's forests provide homes for
animals and insects making them
important for biodiversity
wooded areas also protect our soil from
erosion and extreme weather events
our forests are vital for the bioeconomy
producing not only wood
but fruit cork resin and oils
the european parliament recognizes that
sustainable forest management can
support a crucial economic sector
while helping manage climate change
pests and diseases
that forestry workers would also benefit
from a robust forestry strategy
the jobs within the sector are dependent
on resilient and well-managed forest
ecosystems
in the long term the new strategy should
act as a bridge between national
policies
and eu objectives